[Music]
well you know shout out to our new daddy
elon musk the new twitter daddy
succeeded in buying twitter they
accepted his offer now still a lot has
to happen before this deal actually goes
through okay but i mean the board
unanimously accepted it
jack
dorsey posted on twitter and was like i
think elon is the best person which is
kind of curious a little bit
yeah like he just hires a new ceo like
how much like three four months ago yeah
and now all of a sudden is kind of
changing his tune although he did say
like that's the reason why he hired
perog as the same reason why he thinks
elon's going to be a great twitter owner
got it um which is what
i think like
that they're both annoying
yeah they both are massive losers yeah
sorry sorry
so now what so so the money that he
borrowed from morgan stanley is
like he took
you know it was like 20 million dollars
in debt or something like that that he
took from morgan stanley which is not
cheap yeah
like you don't have to pay the interest
on that every single year 20 million or
20 20 billion yeah
twitter is a business only made
twitter does three and a half billion a
year in revenue that's it a business
roughly the size of the olive garden
yeah it's hilarious he should have
bought olive garden what a [ __ ] i
know right i can't wait till tweets are
not um you don't type in text it's just
gonna look like a poll you just have
four
options to tweet they'll change every
now and then it says he's gonna turn
this [ __ ] to severance yeah before 2069
by doge yeah free speech
and then [ __ ] bill gates free speech
yeah
that's what that's that's what saving
free speech means it's just tweeting for
the words free speech yeah
well you know
he's he's saving the human race one kind
i will say this
elon musk is like impressive at
doing getting [ __ ] done yeah you could
say that but what does he actually do he
did that that's him he [ __ ] did that
yeah he's raised
single-handedly the most amount
of money ever
privately or like as an individual to
take a company private
i just don't [ __ ] crazy i don't
understand what the end game is i don't
get it either i don't understand it
tesla doesn't really make money right
like none of his [ __ ] really makes money
google makes money facebook makes money
apple makes money that's it so now he's
got twitter tesla spacex boring company
yeah
it's all worth a billion dollars or more
which is pretty [ __ ] crazy you saw
that
stupid-ass tweet where he was like oh if
we had a tunnel you wouldn't even
experience a hurricane
no it's like bad mouthing like highways
okay you're saying like oh if we had the
hyperloop
a hurricane could be going up on up top
and you wouldn't even notice it
it's like
ask people in st louis if they agree
with that [ __ ] hacker news speculating
on how twitter will integrate oh this is
so stupid yeah i like this today because
i was like this is just the most
the stupidest nerdiest
interpretation of this i'm surprised no
one has mentioned that twitter is
probably the best social media platform
for interplanetary communication where
low bandwidth and delayed transmission
are fundamental bottlenecks dude
shut up
not talking to aliens you know it's
crazy i saw
this thread of people
getting excited on how they could help
elon buy twitter and that to me
was the lowest of low like oh if we each
buy one share we could transfer it to
elon how many shares is it if we all
band together we could like help him get
i'm like
use only fans yeah
you can get much more interaction with
the creator
than this dude do you think elon [ __ ]
cares that you exist
no no
no no we can help him he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about you no he does not dude he's
literally talking directly to morgan
stanley about raising 20 billion dollars
dude you think you guys on reddit are
gonna raise like anything it's it's
really interesting how delusional some
people are on reddit
their connections to things and
like they write these [ __ ] huge
paragraphs like just fantasizing and
projecting about things it's like shut
the [ __ ] up like you're just making it
up yeah i don't even know like is text
texting not the exact same thing i was
going to tell the grammar what's
happening just as [ __ ] good dude
they've sent
infinitely more like lo-fi messages like
through satellites like years ago yeah
and no one's responded because there's
nothing out there for us
it is so bizarre to be like oh elon's
doing the right thing
like people are gonna be tweeting from
other planets
like dunking on each other from mars
have you seen the twitter video player
you think they could handle
interplanetary communication
they can't get video right that [ __ ]
sucks man that [ __ ] took them like five
[ __ ] years
i don't think they're gonna be talking
through space anytime soon that [ __ ] is
ass have you seen your boys automatic
driving cars those crashed too man oh
yeah lock dogs and kids in when they're
on fire i don't know if this is
up their alley yet my [ __ ] hate for
this dude is so irrational but he's just
annoying all the people that like him
the earth could be on fire and they'd be
sitting there like he he tweeted 420
well it's just like the
yeah it's just like the
extremes that people go to it's like do
you either [ __ ] love him yeah or you
hate him yeah and there's dudes like
this guy on twitter
was like i don't understand the hate for
elon and you know he goes on he's like
he's literally these are the reasons why
he's amazing
and some guy replied and was like dude
if you see investor in a bio
pretty much you can guarantee that guys
that guy's a gold medal at the dick
riding olympics
i think it was maybe felix who said that
i think i don't know yeah that that is
actually a great point watching any elon
q a it's crazy how all the people in
that room want to [ __ ] him people look
at elon as like tony stark
yeah
tony stark
do you like tony stark
i don't got one for that you like tony's
dark dick in your mouth
i mean i don't know i don't i don't hate
elon
i don't love him i i do i'm impressed by
that he just does [ __ ] well first of all
i can't like him because he's just like
a diamond mind baby
and then secondly i think
if you had as much money as him arguably
you could
make some of these things happen
it's just nobody does though
well because i think what it is is that
most investors and billionaires just
like
i think they have a certain degree of
content and they care about their money
i don't actually think elon cares about
money as much as he cares about being
popular
i think that motivates a lot of what he
gets into i guess what i'm trying to say
is i don't feel like he actually cares
about these companies doing well
if he could die famous
i i don't know i think i disagree
there are like way better ways to be
famous and easier ways too what do you
think elon should do to be famous
instead of buying weird-ass companies
podcast
yeah yeah uh go on snl could you have a
youtube channel youtube channel no
definitely
you can't deny that his like
a
bull in a china shop attitude like
definitely pushes things forward i just
think yeah that's a good way of putting
it yeah and you can't deny that but i
just think
he gets a lot more credit than
like for what his products and [ __ ]
actually do and i think people
um
they kind of look at him like some kind
of like inventor or visionary when it's
like it's other people doing that he's
just bringing the dollars to it which
again yeah you can argue is a good thing
it's not only money though it's like
execution making sure that you're like
an actually
like a leader
running a team like he's the ceo of
these companies my impression of him is
he has a lot of money and he buys other
people's good ideas and then he but he
has a lot of money because of what he
did with tesla
really yes
i mean like the
trillion dollar company yeah
i mean i think what's i think what's
more impressive they do with tesla is
promising a lot of [ __ ] getting a lot of
money then not really following through
on a lot of it but he's gotten him a lot
of power like in terms of dollars and
he's the chief engineer too
it's [ __ ] crazy but he doesn't know
anything about engineering he does
he's an engineer no
yeah he is he was accepted to a to do a
doctor of philosophy program in material
science at stanford
i don't know i've just seen like a lot a
handful of people put forward that he
doesn't actually drop out after two
years i would get behind people's
opinion of it more if they
kind of revered him as like some psycho
investor like a like a
like a john mcafee type
it's like man elon's [ __ ] crazy he
just throws money at [ __ ] and he makes
it happen and he's a psycho yeah but i
could get behind silent about it he no
he could even be vocal and say all the
dumb [ __ ] that he does i wouldn't care
but it's this idea that he's like an
inventor and a visionary and like he's
nikolai tesla reinvented which he kind
of is just like buying up patents and
pushing [ __ ] forward it's like that's
the [ __ ] that's annoying yeah that's
fair he's not like your [ __ ] tech
jesus i'm laughing again at the idea of
at the gigafest or whatever his card
slowly veering into the yeah yeah it
just kills everyone there slowly running
over people yeah turn it off why is it
not turning yeah it's killed like oh my
god it's killed like 100 people
[Laughter]
neurolink will
she'll be our first test for neuralink
we will reanimate her using neuralink